i'm rebecca hi
how are you i'm good so nice to see you
again so nice
it's been a long time definitely i
haven't seen you in many months
yeah how many months has it been like
four or five months i bet it's been four
or five months yeah
you're doing all right i'm doing good
how about you i'm doing fine what's
going on with you
nothing really is just floating around
where have you been i've been spending
some time in the valley and just kind of
running through the hills you ever heard
that song i was in arizona and there
were these pink fluffy clouds
just been looking at the sky a lot sorry
where were you sleeping anywhere yeah
just yeah same
same answer yeah i'm always concerned
about where you're sleeping
and is your life better is your life
worse than last time i saw you
it's a well i don't want to say worse i
i was i was like i said i got in this
car accident
and tell me about that well basically it
was just like it was
really freaky um you were walking so i
was walking yeah
and i was trying to well really
ironically enough i just found a whole
bag of shoes
and as i'm coming to like cross the
street because i left some like
cigarettes with my friend
to give her all these shoes this car
just comes out of nowhere like all i
remember is somersaulting
and then i looked down and like my legs
like snapped and i keep trying
like i'm trying to push it back in and
uh
and it wouldn't my bone was completely
snapped in half you're like oh
yeah your my right leg down there yeah
what a scar
oh my god look at this i think my scar
is the most beautiful thing about me
there's a lot of beautiful things about
you
but you've healed yeah what pins in my
like
nails in my legs your pins and your legs
yeah the antipast was it painful
no it hurts sometimes but like the
surgery like i didn't feel a thing
it hurts to walk though
but you're surviving thriving you're
thriving
you seem a little more uh
less out of your mind than some of the
other visits you've yeah
graced me with maybe more like you seem
a little more grounded
composed yeah yeah why is that i don't
know i guess i've just been meditating
more
i've just been more relaxed lately less
frenetic i don't know
i guess the seasons i feel like i don't
know with this
epidemic or sorry pandemic yes
um everything's so much more relaxed so
i'm just wandering streets more at night
like
more taking long walks than i am like
partying is coveted affecting you
um yes and no i feel like i'm kind of
i don't know how to put it covid proves
that the system works
like everyone just bought into it
automatically like that
i don't know how i feel about being on
the fringe anymore because it makes me
feel like so much more of an outcast
because i'm not in the fervor the bra
of it i don't you're not running around
scared
i'm not scared because like well there
was swine flu there was bird flu
i feel like fear feeds fear yeah you
know we have nothing to fear but fear
itself
but there are people dying from it it's
off somewhere fortunately
some are hospitals there are people
dying with starvation all over them
have you talked with your family at all
no no no
i barely got to hold on to a phone oh
yeah do your friends they have friends
yeah you do thank you
so you're not lonely i'm not wrong
you're just drifting around and
yeah i like doing that i don't know why
i like doing it yeah i feel like
you're happy you seem happy yeah but i
feel like i need to judge myself for it
i don't
it's so convenient when it's just me
it's the minute i have to give it a
context you know
do you like this life of no
responsibility no i do i hate that i
love it so much but i do
you look like you've gained some weight
yeah a little bit
a little bit because they had me in
physical therapy so i was like laying in
bed for a month oh that'll do it
yeah i like your outfit thank you
where'd you get where'd you
i found this on the floor and i found
this
like it was just sitting there on a
bridge i was i had it like a cloak like
a druid cloak
and then i turned it and burned it into
a skirt you sure did
you always come up with something
created
so what's your plan for the holidays i
have no idea
no idea
you don't really celebrate holidays very
often living the way i do you know no
you don't sell people
every day is a celebration every day
every day is an excuse so you had an
auto accident
yeah what's the best thing that's
happened to you since i saw you last
i met this rockefeller i spent the night
with him
he was really weird he was really weird
but he was great
i don't know if i want to talk about it
too much don't talk it was like one of
those things you know what i mean like a
conspiracy or like a hush-hush thing
yeah we don't need to
although you know we don't need to get
anybody in hot water yeah
but yeah i just call him mr rockefeller
and he was he's a very you know when
people like i never understood the word
visionary
until i met that person because it's
like real estate like i could never
understand commodity
and this person helped me understand you
know
what it is to have more than you know
what to do with
and i like that
yeah i spent a few days and it's
incredible it's incredible
you're learning things you're growing as
a person yes grow from love
i can't remember what that's from yes
i'm a budding blossom i'm a beautiful
petunia
you're certainly interesting thank you i
get lots of interesting people in front
of my cameras
you're somewhere in the top of the list
i don't believe that for a second i've
seen some of the people i found your
page finally
i think the people that you find are
very interesting yeah i feel like i'm
quite dull
i'm really lucky yeah did you watch your
videos i did
what do you think of yourself i'm
strange
i like it though yeah strange nothing
wrong with strange nothing wrong with
strange
i'm more strange than i am weird it just
made me feel like
i felt like a stranger for myself was
kind of separated i just find you
interesting i see tons of potential in
you but
how we're gonna make that turn into
something productive i don't know that
maybe you don't want to it's not that i
don't want to i just have no clue as to
there's certain things i want to go
about but i feel so separated from them
it's not just because of
living the way i do i just like you said
responsibility i have no sense of
responsibility whatsoever i have
no sense of entitlement to anything so
it's hard to
weigh myself down like to need
things you know
so i guess i don't have that
but i don't want it i suppose do you
have any
goals for next year new year's
resolutions
anything to be a better witch
to be a better one i think yeah i think
2021 is going to be very similar to 2020
for you
yeah 2020 was strange you keep thinking
polarity or duality
like the beginning of the year was so
intense for me and then the end of the
year was
really calm but i just wonder if it
means anything
you know things always have to mean
something you know
i just want you to be happy and you seem
to be happy i am happy
do you have moments where you're down of
course who doesn't yeah everybody does
no but
you you i've only seen you one time
where you were down but i feel like i
know how to be satisfied yeah that's
true
i was yeah i was really out of it that
day what was going on that day
i just kind of gotten like roughed about
so having that you know what i mean it
wasn't even skid row it was a really
weird part it was in hollywood like in a
really nice area yeah but
getting roughed up on the street it's
going to be very disconcerting well
disconcerting
it's it's it's a fact of it isn't it
it's supposed to be the
all-giving fact of it it's what people
want to see what's what's the worst
thing about living on the street
i'm suffering help me you know what i
mean like
i don't know um everybody feels sorry
for you pretension yeah
it's not that it's not that many people
feeling sorry for me i just mind people
feeling bad for me in an
abrasive way like
people who give you a certain sort of
attention like
it's not just like what the [ __ ] are you
wearing but let's say let's take that as
an example
okay keep it pushing um people feel
really entitled like
to a piece of you because you're so
because i can it seems like i have
it to give away but are people kind and
generous with you
yeah they see you on the street they say
here's some money for food or here's
some whatever sometimes yeah
yeah because you're not really
collecting money from anything or you're
not panhandling you're not doing
anything i panhandle sometimes you do
yeah i can't picture you panhandling it
looks really funny
it's kind of like i'm very like i have
tactics like i'll be like
excuse me sorry please can you help me
get something to eat i'm actually really
polite and friendly about it
i don't like flying a sign because i
don't like sitting in one place for too
long
yeah i go up to people at mcdonald's and
just asking about me food
did you find like the shop owners and
people like that are fairly kind
and no one no one treats me badly i
don't know if it's because of how i
dress or how i am or maybe because my
tone's a little softer yeah you don't
look you don't look like you're trouble
well it's not like i'm walking on your
head but you're not i went to fendi
i went to fendi like a month ago and i
remember the guy told me i smelled bad
but then i went to chanel and they let
me try and close it was really weird
chanel let you try and close yeah let me
try and close the game yeah it's pretty
cool yeah
i was shaved i'd shaved that day on
melrose
i like my eyes well you're very handsome
and clean shaven you probably come off
like
like you might be just an exceptional it
could actually be something of myself if
i shaved i should get that
electrolysis done of the beard i just
don't like that i have facial hair
but it's one of those things to be an
eccentric millionaire with bad shoes yes
i'd be an extension millionaire about
shoes i am an eccentric millionaire
without shoes
thinking is being
you're going to you're going to memphis
i really i really love
i love like cajun culture it's so
different from out here
very different i love swamps yeah
louisiana is a great state when i was in
when i was in new orleans i spent a lot
of time at swamps
and just i like you said like
hillbillies out of hillbillies oh this
new movie is coming out called
this new movie that came out called
hillbilly elegy yeah i heard it i like
thought
i like that you can give something it's
like dignity like that's what you do you
know i mean you give things dignity
in in a really but in a nice way in a
confusing way but in a nice way
i try to be respectful of every everyone
but it gives hillbilly substance it was
like that movie winter's bone
it gives them a being you know
because i love appalachia i love like i
feel like that's so separated from
american culture very different yeah
because it's not as it's like another
country
it's not it's not like it's not as
chinese i don't know how to say it
it's not as like factory farmed no it's
there are no chain
restaurants or stores or anything it's
just there might be a gas station
within there are places like that and i
love that
people who maybe don't appreciate the
mist of where they are
yeah you get a every time i come back
from there i have a whole new
appreciation for
modern tv yeah it's just like oh my god
it's such a different world
do you get bad self service there is no
cell service there is no cell service no
there's no cell service there you have
to drive to like one of the larger
cities to get
oh god wow yeah i'm unreachable when i'm
there
well there you go can't do anything
yeah it's it's very very isolated in all
kinds of different ways but that's a
good thing
or it can be yeah i'm obviously
fascinated with it
i'm sure i'm sure i'll be back again
when the weather warms up
i hate the cold so i'm going to avoid it
i hate the cold that's why i'm in l.a so
i'm in california
i love the weather we were just talking
about florida before we started shooting
oh the aaron you and i both love florida
i love florida i don't know why
yeah there's something about florida
that's really great yeah it's really
loopy
you know people are like kind of wired
differently there
of miami people really know how to party
in miami i feel like people don't know
how to party you know they
people know how to party in miami
i bet you're fun to party with life's a
party
take risks yeah risks are a great thing
are you fun to party with mark
well let's see i mean what do you mean
by party because i'm not i'm not a
get drunk and smoke weed i don't smoke
i'm not a dancer
i'm not a drinker or a smoker so i i
but i have fun 24 like all the time i
have more fun than anybody
i'm having more fun than anyone i know
but i'm never drinking or smoking or
yeah going to parties
but doing this project is so much
there's been no parties because of color
yeah i can imagine you enjoy
doing what you do this has been the best
year of my life how long have you been
doing this before
a year and a half hot and heavy i was
i've been doing it for 10 but
but 10 and i got divorced and then i
started again and i stopped and i
started and i stopped and
the last year and a half has been pretty
much every day
and i'm i love it i don't see myself
stopping
yeah that's great i wish i had that
devotion or something
i think it's the key to happiness yeah i
was thinking about this the other day
that so many people are focused on like
winning
or or achieving or not not achieving
winning like like if i
won the lottery or if i got a great job
and made lots of money if i had a great
house a great car
great whatever i'd be happy and i see so
clearly how
that means nothing yeah it's
it's it's conquering your fears that
makes you happy
i think it's the idea because if you
really want to be happy truly fulfilled
and like wow i'm having a great
week day month whatever year if you're
conquering your fears you're gonna feel
that way yeah whereas if you won the
lottery
three weeks later you're like you've
lost a lot of your winners always end up
really messed up they lose their friends
and family and they're broke with
everything yeah
it's not it's not the case money is not
gonna make you happy
you think it would it's not about money
or material things it's about finding
things you actually love some people are
so focused on an
end game you know what i mean that
they'll be like oh in 20 years i want to
have
50 million dollars okay but then once
you get there
you're old and decrepit and you're fat
and you know you're having a [ __ ] 20
year old russian hooker because nobody
loves you
you you it's not that you lose your soul
you just
there's there's no the purpose behind it
is very lofty
you know but you mentioned risk a little
while ago and risk
and fear and courage are all kind of
closely tied they're all related and
they're all basically the same thing
to me and so many people are
risk averse and i'm the opposite
like if i find something i'm not saying
stupid risks but
risks that are if if they work out and
if you have
if if they're dependent on courage and
conquering fears then that's a risk i'd
love to take
yeah you ever been mountain climbing or
anything like that it's not my thing
i can't have a fear of hype yeah i mean
yeah like conquering fears and doing
things that are really that scare the
crap out of me i do all the time
yeah but not i'm not gonna go
parachuting or
bungee jumping or climbing mountains or
anything like that i feel like things
irritate me more than
i fear them like pain pain is annoying
to me
it's an inconvenience it's an
inconvenience of being
you know i wonder if there's a way you
could rewrite laws of nature like
you know they say the law of attraction
or the law of gravity
what if you made it illegal to feel pain
you know people always think of
suffering or misery or sadness people
don't think of pain
i just wonder it's just one of those
things well i think one of the laws of
the universe is for every negative
there's a positive like so you broke
your leg and there's something
positive from that experience yeah
there's something positive that came
from that breaking your legs
like maybe you're gonna live more
precautiously and that
might be a good thing for you or you
might the time you spent in the hospital
might have
made you wake up to something that you
didn't realize about yourself or the way
you're living or
there's always a positive i watched a
lot of reality tv
but yeah there is always you know they
say silver lining
well rebecca it was so great seeing you
what a great surprise
i'm packing up and going to the airport
and then you showed up
yeah i really thank you for fitting me
in well thank you take care of yourself
i will
i hope you come back many more times i
hope so too
you're okay yeah i'm great
i'm great you are great you're
you're really great thanks okay
we'll talk soon okay thanks